la parole est à madame corina vert pour
le groupe l'est républicain vous avez la
parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
ça va mieux oui sauf pour les chômeurs
les entrepreneurs les investisseurs
l'économie nationale les plus fragiles
la ruralité somme toute ça va mieux
sauf pour les français comme dirait lui
même le président de la république
pas de bol le gouvernement commente avec
une certaine forme de déni et finalement
d'indécence les résultats calamiteux du
chômage publiés chaque fin de mois et
plus encore pour le mois d'août
pourtant cette période est
habituellement portés par les contrats
saisonniers
l'augmentation des demandeurs d'emploi
de catégorie a c'est à coups de 50 mille
deux cents personnes soit une hausse de
1,4 pour cent c'est historique depuis la
crise de 2008
triste record enregistrée malgré les
malices et les tours de passe-passe de
chiffrage
sans compter les renforts d'emplois
aidés créés en escadron depuis 2012 vous
espériez une inversion de la courbe
mais force est de constater que la
croissance ne concerne que le chômage
quel que soit le critère observé il n'y
a aucune baisse pire encore le nombre de
chômeurs des catégories d et e
et quand les chômeurs en stage en
formation en maladie en contrats aidés
s'est envolé et le nombre de personnes
passaient des catégories a b ou c à la
catégorie des a littéralement explosé en
2016 passant à 90 milles 800 personnes
soit plus du double en un an
derrière ces chiffres il y à des hommes
et des femmes qui souffrent qui vivent
de réelles difficultés parfois même des
familles qui se déchire les français
souffre la france coule
il vous reste sept mois monsieur le
premier ministre la question est simple
que comptez-vous pour éviter la noyade
merci pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame l conneries
milices du travail de l'emploi vous avez
la parole pour deux minutes maximum
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice corinne imbert comme
vous bien évidemment je sais que
derrière ces statistiques froide
il ya bien sûr des hommes et des femmes
qui se battent un impact fort sur leur
famille
parfois une perte d'estimé de soi de
confiance en soi et un impact sur les
enfants
bien évidemment nous sommes tous
conscients de cela il n'y a pour moi
aucune dérobade
aucune et je crois pouvoir dire dans cet
hémicycle qu'à chaque fois j'ai assumé
les choses oui les chiffres du mois
d'août sont en effet mauvais les
chiffres du mois d'août montrent une
hausse de demandeurs d'emploi en
catégorie a de près de 50 mille deux
cents mais il faut être aussi lucide et
ces chiffres ne remettent pas en cause
la trajectoire
cette trajectoire permettez-moi d'ici de
le rappeler nous le savons tous qu'ils
soient bons ou mauvais je le dis à
chaque fois tous les mois
il faut regarder les choses sur au moins
trois mois c'est ce qu'apprend également
l'ensemble des services statistiques que
dit que dit l'insee le chiffre du bit et
que bien souvent vous nous envoyez quand
on parle des comparaisons
internationales que le chômage a baissé
en france en un an de 10 5% à 9 9%
voilà la réalité et en même temps et en
même temps nous avons lancé le plan
d'urgence pour l'emploi en janvier
dernier pour nous donner toutes les
chances pour combattre justement ce
fléau qu'est le chômage pour donner
toutes les chances aux demandeurs
d'emploi notamment les moins qualifiés
alors non il ne s'agit pas de trucage
statistiques que de lancer un plan de
formation avec les présidents de région
concrètement quand avec le président
retailleau que nous voulons développer
l'emploi local à saint nazaire pour
justement limiter le recours au travail
et hachée pour développer la
qualification des demandeurs d'emploi
pour qu'ils aillent sur ces emplois
voilà la réalité du plan 500000
formation c'est une exigence morale
c'est une exigence sociale c'est une
exigence économique et embauche pme
c'est quoi ces sept cent vingt mille
demandes portés par des pme justement
donc nous sommes toujours déterminés à
accélérer les choses parce que nous le
savons nous devons créer beaucoup plus
d'emplois dans notre pays
c'est ce que nous avons commencé à faire
oui ou non depuis un an
185 mille emplois nets créés voilà aussi
la réalité notre politique madame
humbert pour quelques secondes
monsieur savin puisse hier à dammam nice
vous disiez 140 mille emplois donc c'est
bien en 24 heures soit augmenté de 40
mille emplois peu importe les chômeurs
en formation je vous le rappelle par
définition ne sont pas des personnes en
situation d'emploi et non pas de
contraintes travail alors cessé de
reporter la faute assumer agissez
pendant quatre ans c'était la faute du
gouvernement précédent
hier encore vous disiez que le problème
ce ne sont pas les chômeurs le problème
c'est le chômage
soyons sérieux nous attendons
effectivement du gouvernement qu'il se
préoccupe riz enterrement du travail et
de l'emploi
encore faudrait-il pour cela faire
preuve de courage et d'humilité
merci